now good afternoon thank you for joining
us at 4 I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm
Christian Casados it's a case involving
a repeat DUI offender our eight new Zone
investigators have followed for more
than a month a woman accused of her
seventh DUI set free after several Court
appearances until today 8 news now
investigator David charge the only
reporter in court as she was taken into
custody David police arresting Marion
Reyes Rivero on her seventh DUI charge
in mid-october and it took until today
for a judge to set bail as we have seen
delay after delay
a bailiff takes Mary and Reyes Rivero
into custody on five thousand dollars
bail police in Henderson arresting her
more than a month ago on a charge of
driving Under the Influence with a
suspended license her seventh DUI since
2007 in August CCSD police arrested
Reyes Rivero for DUI her sixth in that
August case police pulled Reyes Rivera
over hours after she closed out an
earlier DUI case having completed a
10-week program Marion Reyes Rivero the
process of actually getting charged for
her latest reported DUI has taken weeks
so I'm assuming you're not asking me
this uh older any longer right um
shortly after that arrest on that
seventh DUI charge judge Sam Bateman
legally could not hold Reyes Rivero on
bail because prosecutors said they
hadn't received her blood tests and no
criminal complaint was filed you can't
drive you understand uh no driving
whatsoever two weeks later prosecutors
still hadn't filed charges citing a
delay at the Henderson crime lab they
informed us that all the Henderson
Police Department Labs scientists that
are employed at that lab they're out of
town this week at a all at the same time
yes
prosecutors eventually got those results
filing charges last week they then gave
Reyes Rivero a week to review the
charges against her which brought us to
Monday and you have the substantial
concerns regarding the situation that
we're dealing with here
now the prosecutor asking the judge to
set bail at 50 000 as you heard the
judge set bail at five thousand and if
Reyes Rivero makes that five thousand
dollar bail she will have to wear an
ankle monitoring bracelet though a judge
pulled her license back in June the
judge today ordering her once again not
to drive I'm David charns 8 News Now
thank you David also the city of
Henderson refuted the prosecutor's
statement about the crime lab a
spokesperson previously said there was
no staff related delay to get those
blood tests